hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to go with you through sprt and
bbig price action those two stocks are
right now squeezing so the questions we
are having is how high can it go and why
is it squeezing once we know why we're
gonna be able to answer the question how
long is it gonna last so let's get into
it
[Music]
so uh in no particular order let's start
with sprt so here i'm gonna show you
guys how to combine technical analysis
with analysis about volumes uh market
capitalization um short interest
everything and we're gonna see
how we find the targets and what we do
here so all right we start with sprt so
we are going to use a yet wave theory so
i know what you guys are gonna tell me
you're gonna tell me yeah but during a
squeeze this is not working at all wrong
it's working very well why because
actually those theories have been built
based on emotions of investors and there
is no better place for emotion than a
squeeze all right
a small thing that i want to show you is
look for example at the
volumes traded
so we have here around 100 million
shares
even 160 million shares traded one day
then 100 million look at the market cap
guys
up so sprt
the assigned number of shares is 24
million so it's basically traded a few
times the float share so do you think
and the shorts are banned so let's check
the shorts
so this is my synthetic short
spreadsheet i hear uh retrieve all the
information about the option market i
then check what is the current exposure
usually using the delta associated to
each option and then check what is the
maximum synthetic short which is uh when
the call options are all in the money
this is giving me information about the
gamma which is the difference between
the exposure market makers having now
and the exposure they would have if the
price goes higher and whenever this
gamma is huge i know that there's going
to be bullish momentum on the upside
here for sprc we're having 65 percent of
short interest
and we can go up to 90 guys all right so
the total short
is and we have 25 of regular short which
is uh a lot as well so for now the total
short is 65 plus 25 so 90 and it can go
up 215
all right so this is the first very
interesting information so there are
roughly 25 million shares short in this
market so whenever you see that the
volume traded is 100 million it means
that it's not only a short covering all
right it's everybody buying and selling
you know there is a lot of scalping in
this uh kind of environment so this is
the reason why technical analysis
applies actually very well and i'm gonna
show you what we have already did and
what we will keep doing uh on my discord
so first what is interesting once you
have this data is to see where this
synthetic shot is coming from so here
you can see right away
the green cells are the big ones so here
i have october 15th
september so i have roughly two that are
big so october and september and what is
on the upside 30 and 20 right so 20 is
on the downside okay so this won't
create gamma on the upside so the gamma
comes from here so we have until the
17th of september i mean until the 17th
of september market makers are gonna be
under pressure so this is one first very
good information and
we have roughly 23 percent difference
between the synthetic shot now and the
synthetic shot if all the collapses are
in the money so basically above 30
which we are
so they're gonna keep buying even when
the time is just passing this is
converging towards delta one right now
the delta of this is 67
okay and if if time passes this is gonna
converge to one so every day market
makers are gonna buy shells first
information
now we going back to the chart
so this is the first thing i wanted to
show you where is the synthetic shot
coming from to know for how long it's
gonna last and to show you that
everybody is uh getting into this trail
all right which is the reason why
technical analysis is very helpful so
here the first thing you do we're gonna
first start to apply elliott wave theory
so we need to find five waves so if you
don't know where to start you just take
a big move so here definitely we have
one and you start from here and you try
to count five waves you need to find the
beginning of a cycle so here i have
clearly a beginning of a cycle okay so
this is a one two three four five all
right
then we i'm going to show you how to
find targets but first we build our uh
countings so if this
is one wave maybe not complete i'm
trying to find the next one
okay one two three four five okay and
then here we have a larger uh one okay
so i'm going to put it in yellow but for
now we're wondering
so we have two information here is that
most likely we will go higher i'm gonna
show you the targets and second one is
that then it's gonna there's gonna be a
pullback probably lasting longer maybe a
few months and then maybe one more wave
up
so for now we are not sure of anything
but uh the first thing we want to know
is how high this can go right now so
here is my answer i'm gonna here try to
apply uh fibonacci projections that
actually work very well in this type of
environment so you measure one plus
three
sorry not in this one we're gonna we are
here on the daily so we're gonna zoom in
so we are here bam bam in what seems to
be a fifth wave
and we wonder how high this fixed wave
can go so we do the same thing all right
again so here in this fifth wave so here
you have the fourth all right and the
fifth is starting here guys so
one two three four five okay then i'm
gonna put this
so now we're starting to have some very
interesting information
because we can see that in this fifth
wave so it's probably the last wave
before correction and no surprise it's
probably gonna arrive around the 17th of
september and we are wondering what is
the target for this so we measure one
plus three and we apply to the bottom of
the force all right once again guys this
is coming from here you just type elliot
wave bam you go in the pdf
and you go to the 17
ninths page if i remember well
bam all right here you have everything
basically all the interesting
information of this book is here guys so
for those who are lazy to read
everything just go to this page and here
we have a lot of information so the
fifth wave is usually equal to 0.618 or
1.618 times one plus three so this is
the first thing we're going to apply the
0.618 is going to 58 so it's not
possible because we have already reached
this level so we go to the next one so
the first information we get from this
is that the target for early september
is 110 so i'm not saying we're gonna go
there for sure i'm saying that if we
push higher and we saw that we have some
room for market makers to buy so
it's for me likely that this happens
uh then we're gonna find resistance and
take in perfect takings around this
level all right
so this is i think a very good
information and then we probably gonna
have a correction i mean this would be
another story uh as far as i'm concerned
i'm here i posted an alert on my discord
uh two days ago and yesterday i'm a
buyer here so i bought around at the 30
level but very small quantity i'm a
heavier buyer lower if we go a bit lower
you can see that here the 50 period is
acting as support so we might not go
lower but you know you can start to
invest here a little bit and once again
we have targets around 110.
now second one very interesting bb ig
guys so what do we have here so same
thing we are gonna try to find a move
and split it into five waves and guys
this is pretty obvious here right so one
two
three four five actually it's not that
obvious you have many countings you can
make we don't know if it's one two three
or if it's one two which would push much
higher but this is to me the best
counting all right
and
here
once again guys i posted this yesterday
so i'm going to show you first how to
enter this kind of moves you first need
to spot whenever a wave is finished on
my discord on monday
everybody is on friday i posted an alert
here around four because i saw the
breakout here and i saw the mass the
massive synthetic shot so it was looking
like this would squeeze harder which
happened then i was saying here take
profits take profits around 775 and 11
so in this area a lot of people did
which is very good and then people were
asking me on monday or should i get in
should i get in where what level should
be buy and i was just saying wait wait
because we had no information at this
time we needed to see where is the top
of the third once we know that this wave
is complete so here for example you have
a breakout that tells you that it's
complete then you have a lot of
information you for example know the
length of the third so you're gonna
apply this you know you're in the fourth
wave all right one two three four so you
know that most likely you will correct
to thirty eight point two percent of
wave three this is what is written here
38.2 times three so four equals this the
reality this is the book written 20
years ago the reality is that even force
waves they usually go to the 61.8
retracement just like second waves this
is what i'm saying so that's why i
posted an order i measured this way and
here i was saying that we can try to
enter using fibs all right it was here
guys
um
so squeeze alerts
and this is what i posted guys when we
were at 7 30 once i knew that we
completed uh the third wave i posted by
6 30
then by again 550 and stop loss at 40.
this is not financial advice this is
just what i would do and that i'm
sharing with you guys here and on my
discord because i think that this
knowledge that i acquired during my
trading career is to be passed i want to
share everything i know with you guys
and i really enjoyed that you know it
can be helpful for others so here what
we are having so 635 the 50
uh 550 the 61.8
uh retracement so here we we got
executed on our first order we didn't
get executed on the second one just for
a little it went to 554 we had another
place at 5 15. so we didn't get executed
here but we got executed a bit higher
now in terms of targets so we are in the
trade we are happy now in terms of
target where could it go so guys
same thing
all right you measure one plus three you
apply to the bottom of the force and
this gives you uh targets so you have
the one to one or the one two one point
six one eight that are levels that
usually uh happen
so here i would say 18 all right this is
an ambitious target but that is
realistic to me we of course have
resistance at 11 that's why what we're
doing on my discord actually we are uh
so managing two portfolios uh one with
aggressive orders another one with
conservative orders we sometimes take
the same
stock in both portfolios and we share
everything with you guys
the difference is that for aggressive
orders we have tighter stop losses and
we have higher targets so here we gonna
put this trend in both portfolio i think
for now we only put it in the aggressive
portfolio so the target is going to be
around 18
and i think that this target is
achievable once again
why am i am i bullish here guys you
check the synthetic short interest and
it's absolutely massive massive massive
look at that guys
bam bam bam give it some time it's
computing
so once again what is going to be very
interesting here is to check where this
synthetic shot is coming from once you
get this information you are able to
know what are gonna be the dynamics of
the market until this position expires
and you can also check if you have some
wow 95 all right guys so we are
increasing more and more here we were at
60 two days ago so we are just going
higher and higher so this is another
pressure that market makers are gonna
have and that they're gonna probably try
to buy shares whenever they have a deep
so that's why i think that buying the
deep and bbig is a good idea this is
what most market makers would probably
do
as they are short so here where is it
coming from same thing guys we just open
it and we we look for the greens so here
we have a green here we have a green
bam bam so you have a lot but basically
they're coming from september
okay so most of it comes from here the
biggest one is this one so 7.5 so we are
net but we have this one and this one so
the upside oh and we have an october so
you see this stuff might actually
continue until october because i have
more options on october than i had on
sprt so a lot of people bought 10 strike
calls october maturity and 30. uh sorry
11.5 and what else do i have here so at
least you know september
and yeah and october so those are our
time targets you know for the the levels
to be reached so let's see how things
actually develop where are we we are
here so imagine we go right away to the
target then how is it going to look yeah
we might have you know something like
this guys all right and then a one two
three four five
it's possible as well so we're gonna
analyze later what is happening but
probably
if this finishes around 18 then pulls
back okay so this is a very long shot
i'm just doing this right now with you
but i think that here a lot of people
will be buying the dip and this is gonna
be maybe another opportunity uh to enter
this trade but we are not there yet for
now let's see how we can go for this
first wave uh it's on your first wave
and depending on where we go we're gonna
use again thieves you know same
techniques and i'm gonna share
everything with you guys to enter you
know this is going to be a second wave
so probably let's say we go to 18 it's
probably going to correct to the eighth
level so this is going to be another
buying opportunity so hope you guys
enjoyed this video i hope i managed to
explain how i actually set up my trades
how i analyze the market how i use the
option market as an indicator of
potential squeezes and when they could
potentially happen and if you did enjoy
this video guys please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore see you guys